casca also just the attention of
attention first that's my favorite
tangent okay
um is it possible for me to have a
podcast conversation
with somebody who hasn't been caught yet
and because they have the conversation
they still won't be caught
and is that a good idea meaning is there
a safe way for a criminal to talk to me
at a podcast
I would think so
I would think that that someone could I
mean someone who has been living a
double life for for long enough where
you think they're not a criminal
um no no no they would have to admit
that they would say I am AV unit oh you
would want to have a conversation with
AV unit yes
um is there what I'm just speaking from
an FBI perspective technically speaking
because I I so let me explain my
motivation or I think
I would like to be able to talk to
people from all walks of life and
understanding criminals
understanding their mind I think is very
important
and I think there's fundamentally
something different between a criminal
who's still active versus one that's
been caught the mind just from observing
it changes
completely once you're caught you you
have a big shift in your understanding
of the world
um I mean that I do have a question
about the ethics of having such
conversations but first technically uh
is is that is it possible
if I was technically advising you I
would say first off don't advertise it
don't the fewer people that you're going
to tell that you're having this
conversation with the better
um and yeah you could you do it in
person are you doing it in person would
be amazing yeah but they their face
would not be shown face would not be
yeah I mean you couldn't publish the
show for a while they'd have to put a
lot of trust in you that you are not
going to you're going to have to alter
those tapes uh I say tapes because it's
old school you know exactly I'm sure a
lot of people just said that like oh
[ __ ] this old guy just in tape I heard
of VHS was in the 1800s I think
um but yeah yeah you could do it they'd
have to have complete faith and trust in
you that you destroy the originals after
you've altered it what about if they
don't have faith is there a way for them
to attain security
um so uh like for me to go through some
kind of process where I meet them
somewhere where I mean you're not going
to do it without a bag over your head I
don't know if that's the life you want
to live I'm fine with a bag
that's gonna take get taken out of
context but I just I think it's a worthy
effort it's a worth it's worthy to go
through the hardship of that to
understand the mind of somebody I think
fundamentally conversations are a
different thing than the operation of
law enforcement understanding the mind
of a criminal I think is really
important I don't know if you're going
to have the honest conversation that
you're looking for I mean it may sound
honest but it may not be the truth I
found most times when I was talking to
criminals it's lies mixed with half
truce uh and you you kind of it's if
they're good they can keep that story
going for long enough uh if they're not
you know you kind of see the relief in
them when you finally break that wall
down
that's the job of an interviewer if the
interviewer is good then perhaps not
directly but through the gaps it seeps
out the truth of the human being so not
necessarily the details of how they do
the operations and so on but just who
they are as a human being what their
motivations are what their ethics are
how they see the world what is good what
is evil do they see themselves as good
what do they see their motivation as do
they have a resentment what do they
think about love for the people within
their small community do they have
resentment for the government or for
other nations or for other people to
have childhood issues that led to to a
different view of the world than others
perhaps have do they have certain
fetishes like sexual and otherwise that
led to their construction of the world
they might be able to reveal some deep
flaws to the cyber security
infrastructure of our world not in
detail but like philosophically speaking
they might have
I I know you might say it's just a
narrative but they might have a kind of
ethical concern for the well-being of
the world that they're essentially
attacking the weakness of the cyber
security infrastructure because they
believe ultimately that would lead to a
safer world
so the attacks will reveal the
weaknesses
and if they're stealing a bunch of money
that's okay because that's going to
enforce you to invest a lot more money
in defending
um yeah defending things that actually
matter you know nuclear warheads and all
those kinds of things I mean I could I
could see if you know it's fascinating
to explore the mind of a human being
like that because
um I think it will help people
understand now of course
uh
it's still a person that's creating a
lot of suffering in the world which is a
problem so do you think ethically it's a
good thing to do
I don't I mean I I feel like I have a
fairly High
ethical bar that I have to put myself on
and I don't think I have a problem with
it I would love to listen to it